sex ist eine großartige sache aber cam
sex sex unter drogen jetzt bei pixum
science fiction
beim sex kann der mensch die
intensivsten gefühle spüren zu denen
überhaupt in der lage ist aber wie das
immer so oft ist es gibt den drang nach
mehr das gefühl zu verlängern zu
intensivieren seit einigen jahren hat
sich ein neuer trend ausgebreitet der
sich zum sex nennt der begriff
beschreibt gruppensex unter
drogeneinfluss und besseren sex zu haben
nehmen die beteiligten vor oder auch
während des sex drogen zu sich diese sex
treffen können durchaus einige tage
dauern
zu dem phänomen gibt es auch immer
wieder studien mit denen experten
versuchen zu verstehen welche motivation
dahinter steckt welche drogen konsumiert
werden und was die risiken sind neben
den negativen auswirkungen vieler drogen
kommt es durch diese art des gruppensex
auch häufiger zur übertragung von
geschlechtskrankheiten wie hepatitis b
oder hiv nicht von ungefähr sind die
neuinfektionen nach den aktuellsten
zahlen 2014 europa auf 142 1997
gestiegen 2013 waren es noch 136 1235
beliebt sind bei den champs ex anhängern
drogen die intakte gene wirken das heißt
sie verstärken die emotionale
wahrnehmung ein orgasmus oder die nähe
zu einem menschen werden viel intensiver
wahrgenommen die drogen die häufig für
solche zwecke eingesetzt werden sind
crystal meth gp auch bekannt als liquid
ecstasy oder mephedron seltener bei
teurer und auch weniger effizient werden
auch kokain ketamin special day genannt
und alkohol konsumiert die substanzen
wirken auf den kreislauf und treiben
diesen in die höhe der herzschlag wird
beschleunigt neben der wahrnehmungs
steigerung ist auch eine höhere sexuelle
leistungsfähigkeit möglich neuer bei
alkohol die 46 mit verschiedenen
partnern möglich macht der nachteil der
drogen ist allerdings dass sie die
hemmschwelle für ungeschützten sex
herabsetzen weil gruppensex unter diesen
umständen können sich die krankheiten
also währenddessen schon ausbreiten und
bleiben unter umständen auch bis zum
nächsten camp sex treffen und darüber
hinaus unerkannt seinen ursprung hat sex
in der schwulen szene in großbritannien
2014 haben mitarbeiter des sigma
research dass ich mit dem verhalten der
schwulen und bisexuellen szene
beschäftigt eine studie zum thema camsex
durchgeführt dabei konnten sie kein
eindeutiges muster der beteiligten
feststellen sie kommen aus allen alters
und sozialschichten die motivation ein
champ sex teilzunehmen hat allerdings
unterschiedliche gründe
die studie fand heraus dass ein großteil
der champ sechs anhänger ein geringes
selbstbewusstsein haben was ihr
sexualleben angeht die teilnehmer der
studie berichten dass sie zwar ein
intensiveres sexuelles gefühl durch den
sex hatten sie mit ihrem sexualleben
dadurch aber nicht zufriedener wurden
der großteil der fans ex anhänger
scheint sich dem risiko einer
hiv-infektion bewusst zu sein wenn es zu
ungeschütztem sex kommt kann dies bei
vielen auf die erhöhte
risikobereitschaft durch die drogen
zurückgeführt werden andere sexuell
übertragbare krankheiten werden in der
szene allerdings als eher harmlos
angesehen was ein unterschätztes risiko
darstellt camsex ist aber anscheinend
keine sache mehr für die sich nur eine
kleine gruppe eingeweihter trifft auch
in der prostitution spielt der sex und
drogen eine immer größere rolle von der
londoner szene wird berichtet dass dort
immer mehr kunden nach chips ex
verlangen würden
dazu gehöre dann auch dass die
prostituierten die drogen dafür besorgen
müssten das injizieren der drogen wird
in der szene slammen genannt die
prostituierten konsumieren dabei auch
oft auch selbst mit und geraten dadurch
in eine drogenabhängigkeit durch die
hohe nachfrage nach chips sechs steigt
der druck auf die prostituierten diesen
auch anzubieten und durch die
beschaffung der drogen und deren
auswirkungen verdienen viele weniger
geld auch in dieser szene sinkt durch
den drogenkonsum die hemmschwelle auf
safer sex wird er verzichtet es kann
auch zu einer erhöhten
gewaltbereitschaft führen bei der es zu
sexuellen übergriffen kommen kann die
nicht von dem sexualpartner gewollt sind
außerdem erhöhten risiko auf
geschlechtskrankheiten und hiv haben
auch die konsumierten drogen negative
auswirkungen die sigma research studie
kam zu dem ergebnis dass viele
konsumenten bereits einige
krankenhausaufenthalte hinter sich
hatten das ist oft auf die überdosierung
der stoffe zurückzuführen die folgen des
exzessiven drogenkonsums können
panikattacken bewusstseinsstörung
angstzuständen krämpfe oder ein erhöhtes
aggressionspotenzial seien durch die
drogen leitet außerdem das soziale
umfeld der konsumenten da sie einen
großen teil ihrer zeit für fans ex
aufwenden experten raten die aufklärung
über die risiko fördernden eigenschaften
der drogen zu verstärken die gefahr geht
er von den krankheiten aus die durch den
ungeschützten sex übertragen werden was
haltet ihr von diesem trend können
drogen wirklich eine lösung für sexuelle
unzufriedenheit sein und
ist es das risiko dass der konsum mit
sich bringt ist das verantwortbar
schreibt uns in die kommentare und nicht
vergessen zu abonnieren ist kostenlos
und unbedingt das nächste video
anschauen es lohnt sich bis dann bleibt
dran